all right so my morning started out I
woke up after having a zombie apocalypse
dream coolest dream ever I just got on
Twitter I was like the response about
the Fantastic Four trailer and then do a
video about it guess no one wants to
hear my tweets zombie apocalypse dream
which was pretty cool too a new trailer
for fan-forced it came out I would call
it fan for stick cuz that's what the
trailer calls it seriously did you see
that fan for stick it's weird that
marketing campaign right that is 2011
keep the fan for stick has had a road my
god with me anyway I was I heard the
casting I was like good actors don't see
them as the Fantastic Four can you find
out dr. Doom's actually some hacker
named doom Shaw or something like that
you're like is this a joke is it no
snobby Praful states
that's weird nothing about this movie
has appealed to me it's almost like it
was like it was like a trolling oh my
god maybe Jim chefs actually a troll and
he's the one releasing all this
information in which case if he's real
that I guess it's real then like a month
ago people like the movie might not
happen alright so now we have a trailer
so obviously it is happening and I saw
the trailer and for a movie that I had
zero hope for I gotta say the trailer
was actually a pretty good trailer it
has a good tone like I always say always
teaser trailers just needs to show us a
good vibe in the movie this movie hat
looks to have a good vibe via the
trailer it has this realistic grit to it
I really liked the tone of this trailer
it has a good voiceover might be Doctor
Doom might not it sounds like someone
who narrates civilization games we don't
get a look at Toby Kebbell is doom in
this movie or doom shoves or Dom Shaw
but we do get to see a couple of
glimpses you see Johnny Storm turn into
flame you see Ben Grimm comes out of a
rock like those rock transformer things
from when I was a kid remember that
they were transformers they were
transformed into rocks
it really doesn't let them do much
except sit there alright I'm going to
compare this to the ant-man trailer
because the ant-man trailer was like
alright add based on the fact that it's
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it's done probably kind of excited for
it but as a trailer it really didn't do
much for me the fan for stick trailer as
a trailer was a better trailer than the
ant-man trailer and I can't say I'm
looking forward to it given the
information I mean if they're
making I love villains I love it when
people do villains well Doctor Doom is a
pretty awesome villain so if you're
gonna make him a hacker that's just not
Doctor Doom at all then again Doctor
Doom and the other fantastic four movies
wasn't Doctor Doom either he's like oh I
have this in my R&D department made this
bazooka it's like did you make it pretty
sure you're smarter
to make it except in this movie where
you're not maybe tuned well-liked was a
hacker when he was younger maybe he is a
hacker but he's still on every facet of
his life in the movie maybe he is
doctored whom maybe he knows gypsy magic
and he owns a castle in a country it
just happens to be Thacker in his off
time he just gets so bored
it's like man he's only been a hacker
he's like he's just a blogger user
control right because I gotta say those
are the worst kind of humans so at least
you could respect dr. Doom's intellect
before now he's just the kind of a
I want to know how everyone
goes into space and goes to this program
and my god Reed Richards I understand
cuz he's all like super smart oh yeah
you want to go find this other world
cool do that like what do you do I play
softball what do you do I work on cars
cool when I go into space pays to have
smart friends I guess so based on the
merit of this trailer as a trailer
pretty good town and not a bad looking
trailer at all in fact a pretty good one
this is a fan for stick trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it to
the trailer surprise you you liked nub
that looks as bad as I thought it was
going to be when I first heard that dr.
doom was gonna be an internet troll
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]